tensorflow Jas is awesome caris is
awesome would it be extra amazing if
they could work together well I got
great news for you they do stay tuned to
find out just how to import your trained
Karis model into tensorflow Jas
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng glow
and on this episode we're gonna look at
what it takes to import a Karass model
into tensorflow Jas tensorflow Jas has
many functionalities but perhaps one of
the most exciting ones is its ability to
operate in collaboration with other
tools we're really seeing a future where
you can do machine learning across a
range of platforms languages and devices
all optimized to perform at their peak
performance in the situation they're
most well suited for the tricky thing
about loading a Karass model into
tensorflow Jas is that Kerris models are
typically saved as hdf5 files using
something like model dot save my model
h5 tensorflow Deus provides a tool the
tensorflow Jas converter which is used
to convert your Kerris model into a
format that tensorflow Diaz can consume
which is a folder containing a file
called model JSON let's see that in
context with the Charis model that we've
been using in the last few episodes in
the episode where we converted a Karass
model to a tensor flow estimator we also
exported our Kerris model as a dot h5
file so we'll head on over to that
kernel and download the file from the
output section so I've got my Kerris
model downloaded and named it
caris model h5 just to keep things clear
which files from which library now I
need to run pip install tensorflow Jas
in my Python environment to install the
converter notice that the pip library
name is tensorflow Jas
even though the converter we'll use is
called tensorflow j/s converter okay so
we've got the converter and we got the
Charis model all in one place one last
step before we run the converter though
I'm gonna create a new folder because we
need to store the outputs of the
tensorflow j/s model files let's just
call it TF j s files now we can run the
converter passing in a flag to indicate
that it is a Karass model and we'll also
need to pass the path to the Charis hdf5
file and that folder we just created so
it has a destination to put the new
files in once our converter has run
let's take a peek inside the folder we
see that it's got not only in the model
dot JSON file but three additional files
there's a group one shard one of one
group to shard one of one and Group
three shard one of one these shards are
here to enable faster repeat loading by
the browser the files are below the
typical cache size limit so they'll
likely be cached for subsequent calls
when you're serving them so after you've
successfully converted your Kerris model
to model JSON just got one last step
left now to load it into your JavaScript
thankfully this is a one line task go
ahead and use TF model load to point to
the URL where you have the files hosted
and tensorflow J s takes care of the
rest it's worth pointing out here that
since the model is operating on the
client side using JSON files it's not a
great use case if you need to secure
your model for that you'll have to stick
with client-side models alright so now
you're ready to import your own caris
models into tensorflow j s go forth and
make the next great machine learning
inspired game on the web thanks for
watching this episode of cloudy AI
adventures and if you enjoyed it please
like it and subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
for now try loading your Kerris model
into tensorflow j s and see just how
ease
units